the first tutorial no understand what
you know how it works basically johann
is a place concept.de run to many of the
simple things and you're winning
tutorials learning is still the cases
you can use case for learning and
results for computer vision problems act
registers the  his network from
scratch my name is free trade pact at
nintendo it may well thought out way like
the psalms nice tools and library
slider mobile phone open booklet is like note
to self way out of a youtube at the
dfb press conference talk about that you
can follow him  on to i bet you haven
priest internet is not great to have
instruction set you can set up und
google talk google cola in googles cloud
internet so internet ist
so das ist motto talk about some basics
and the basics of machine learning
attention to be together like  automatic
dependent which
because how going back in port switches
amazing example concept switcher the
data loader samplers and transformation
to work then basic  ally in the last dance
for learning and visualization users
every breath you take part of the top
ten have lots of little different things
unfortunately nobody whips
who knows akku walldorfer dedicate it said apple
client who n tv offheim i can look at
some time service is great  cherry sms
flatrates to barry bonds and execute the
new here you can do much cooler
so hirai in porto cervo function
argument xvid marketplace expert
results investing business active
here users can die diggers in page and the
people like some people have you spencer
fleet well-known dancers flores  changing
at the rwe execution mode that will if
so if there was like you can use dem
bagger if you so using the basic i bet
you can't do wah diddy in the seducer
so that's business amazing if so if
we bagger in the middle  hear you can get
well you think it is just after it
however never debug the special teams on board
plugin i bring to is the
wfp the image app networks from scra  tch
the bit of hippie look at it blog
aggregator values ​​relative ranking
bathed max live as well as you should
awaken that is personal the domain reseller
liked so much like it hot house jazz
thing about blank now that you in
python the zwd back to you can do it
[Music]
interfaces simple interface chemmedia
understand reiter and i think both
complicated mpi research des public
viewing papers in south of the george
implementation and implementation and we
like a journey of choice the really
great the planning library software the
fiasco obedient file servers male
stayed
the  worst case that end of low dancer
florists big one in the great if you
want blood pressure stance of service
great day ahead dancer afloat transform
3gs google product er ist los auf moment
ins great things about mxn adwords
delicious dynamic light weight watchers
the great interface delicious  high level
interface trier the burning bridges
david leukert career service award of the
laser as  reference is twitterfeed of
directors later much
michael friedrichs lotto features will also be a
libraries of the airport also available
for like in between the like
computer vision part of text inforadio
ich helfe few cool cars is like the fast
and which is no fun the juku links in
the  capital requirements the stanford course an
automatic documentation this great
the quick on exempel very quick
tutorials rabbi marvin win here at the
conference where to learn sometime
his pieces to win with get started
to wear leveling engineering of justice
network in the looks like here we have
to network  as well as saleh standard imports
in port orchard dear costs including import
torchance network package on modules on
the fff functional interface which is
very similar to the national
dieter kemper unfortunately so last financial
network just a feeling that what you can
do you have the sense sequences
sequential is  basically justel is
roddick osterbrink of players  place like
here he had to recognize roddick but net profit
ames nce häfele which is called
confronted with one in channel21 the
output channels of the players said
today that is exactly the location a
bit louder keywords in general
hewlett packard end sequences network access
point of you think we want to build
wittmann complicated model like what
remains to create a class in herrieden
motto now clear the raika roughly
franconian josef superlative constructor
on japan klaas huizing here will live
band slayer space and the same as
memories of the cars when you have to
define award function and function
basically get some day in the case and
parts of the data access layer the way
you are new here you can use to find
your data floss for julia graf
maybe know the base and star brand thats
the
most lucrative
thats racing and lots of  automatic
transmission protocol service for making
sense
further basic dancer louis lost
kurt was billeted que  stions problems
but then to grasp how much
he likes youtube speed-dating asics
gfk basic import like streaming services
jnf samoa import from web.de
the landlady protégé
a monitor is of course the
best thing about ipod and chances are
red we like  numbers and sometimes you
can you can create the identity metrics
pnp
if we can this sail
world.com dancer shall interfaces ist
you can am great lake random dancer
racing and i like you can have one value
uk vector witches of value switch to the
people links  a dancer generation
of that you can have easily again
people in front of people two people
he can't for the pag unfortunately
there will be
that is obviously going into office a
statement from the ex here of the main
krines morgana is she okay from the ex justin and
you can get  the shape the question is it
like paints that of the people
yes yes
thank you just american okay for
interfaces in numbers icann news metrics
multiplication here again  r ex transport
times
here is today capital this is
multi view transporter made and
suppliers of rochester new edition things
like most of the operator celebrations
like i can say that for server
installed or elsewhere in place
operation
blablabla have elsewhere in place
[music
] with me  is great because it is like crazy
broadcasting brixlegg and conditions of
broadcasters element from here the
extended reception in the preview version may be
loud before the work of a limited by now
it's almost a very very nice ping is
a traffic light system and makes them all you're
strange  it easy to convert vom
dammtor chances to bambi as well as hitachi
data systems
[music] has
now
fallen and which correct you say
you need you can surf basic reaction we
can calculate middle rib chiefs of
operations is the package colt auto
degree in the web creatives of  eurocities
names optimization for example exempel
so here we create dancers
to england america sv wan  ne 11
rebounds calculation and dancers get
the new times of ten to automatically
tracks your calculation service force
computation the glass walls oriented
interface of change for you have this
context manager education iuce contact
manager before there
special cars convertible and if you want
to record radiohead the potential to  the
track and the hero how violently die leike
tencel australian circuit tutorials
online in the lodge of the man they used
the rebirth of thought you don't and you
go go tänzer cfs very gpu friendly and
we can just tänzers gpu date up
education so what  do you have to do is
available
[music]
the state of discussion what happened to
be used to any algorithms with noris
network so you can really do anything
our gp2 male choirs as dancers
corrective faster than you can get
married on speed up to you need to
install the to end customers the enzer is
yes but do conde a star and cuda in
salt lake city at that time active giant 22
then you have d  u there the representative of
nvidia is new that and if you use
counterattack into the goal
torchwood cleaned library samuel anaconda
peña hot stuff is the way but if you
work with it in some and any thing is
amazing
just before you there enormous deep
insights of  cuda architecture
subscription senders warrior within you have lots
of the model there cuba in the ju basic
life calls gpu almost heftes to device
and you don't have to noticed the fl
statement warns
economy is in the works for a long time it knows sales operations
schott would have  our gpu into the home cinema
or moving the datagroup future
overhead nation if the yield will be
a you can trust tested and makes sense
to move computation on you have to great
weekend with a very simple switcher
optimizer great and decent work so here
you can use orders may der  would have before
and create including data access and we're
very simple when the people unfortunately
sub-people output discussion
service with lucky lord the position of
half of the bet y  ou can do it like you
can have live data perel Staffel dancing
stage no retailer typical up to use
the practical labels complete appearance
of the motto supermassive parameters with
jacks or better
i would now put it in port
switches one one in the pot dimensions and
a half men car three people on the
east ring calls for function and function
data best mourning
here here here you can be the
automatically location at conti is here
the comics 1 boss waved pete
documentation ok middle line crash
motto our gp3 series baywatch s3 core
cpu intel apple machines  model jude law
center optimizer model los optimal
system model
this is the los angeles inc here to
device with my model to patients and of
course of a wide variety of optimal
strong winds bothersome brothers and i
have a dream i thought the flag election on
the for  the team really has a lot of
action with use and explain will be in
the nn module us association here
a young crea  tives social problems
model los my optimal training lukas
passion
yes
a move right way of the model to keep
you because the model hess parameter
center parameter students optimal is
on under tv internet data and model
parameters he damn about maybe
data our gpu and shader and
industrial fair  bypass operation and gets
to data rescue days of the maria ward about
hesse ljv you are and for some reason
your device is a trekking bike one
workstation large suspend mountain bikes
modified that a work in any way that
you
okay okay
the model was optimal
lost functional training lucentis is
der don t like about what if we use
cases asking you can you save it takes
over here you have to do it yourself
now again so far
first of may be one of the biggest takes
you have to model entertainment and we
have the warmth and rain  motor example
drop out is only available light active
in the train mode basically you your
network and you like one a m  exican news
man at the end was motto help at
emsländer basically so don't forget that
the bet you have to say optimizer zero
gravity than the great and the whale
watching you have to set the grapes of
the automation
because like pasta data to the data extra
model louis dowler production area
defense clever here go the pasta data
model kate moss the software optimal
update promise of here and repair the
data model in gypsum am fashion and here's
why not interested in bregenz or
splitter data in trainings et variations
it goes to school here  des data down
here validation data
in the after what they used to have you
here you can zionist end
here it says in great interest a
booklet parameters of the model told
grandpa michael path of the pyramid on the
motto we want to optimize part of the
different  parts of the model and hate
you dad
[music]
de los pueblos the crises 100 79 106
that is machine ring acted flawlessly
driving fifty five will prev  andes have
more machine learning for one in
depth notebook widget going to show you
but if you want to do everything from
scratch hier ist in files hier ist
machine learning one thing if you wanna
get off starts crashing
model and  work like you have to training
ludwig
under the motto made the tears of course
you be there for you can't wait what you
can can you can you can you modify model
döring training and yes you can cost
keyboard you have something to do some
crazy  like every time you split the
number of the world
harry debugging visit the best of five
friends only the excavators from cablecom was
that's not so that print line
debugging here you can apple at a
finca story fine scale for problem loans
printer of course des tus
meddersheim  the cases when you say the flow
here the excavator pbb bite the excavator
barry handy i would have hoped for a user
players of what you can do is basically
h  here a port said trace function
function here and tracing here in my
function icann luck a little better
max heinzer manager worldwide hope
that it all you really need this great
if you need some more context where are
you need to do some of magic software
together computing  system bagger and you
can get in new networks switch module
sat the record total data access and
creating what you again in harriets from
nvidia will in japan autoteile forward
wrong passes someday press data
line function and results have all the
things that often the first ever do i
think about people relatively modern
and in discos 1 no
that was five teams triathlete here that
is rhi times when this is what should
get off the exorcist to make sure that
the one that got five dances shape 5
point we wanted
he knows the tricks of  bagger there is
no lex here the word expected from the ex
now is so execute nextel an ok media
can look at the locals
this will be alex here another ex  hibit of
metal statistics here is when eva
testor because the refueling of execute begin
and remove the tracks of course
is so amazing and mobile networks
yes what about the saints pizarro had
to its performance engines peissenberg
home performance compared to the extent
of low end of  low computer slaves can
do like a bunch of optimization sochi
on the black sea projections about the
same speed mxn etfs in some of which
were they make some time so much faster
if tens of europe i'd choose what to
say
ja als pink so what about  memory
consumption as a left dancer florida
depends on the water
august is a dancer fled
that's even further and feel
like about what if you had dancers from
modeling junior grafites find you
can then page is much more dynamic
and you can have sent random numbers  in
jos luhukay
who is nothing from microsoft and facebook
fanbase criticism enemy format for
exchange in computational graph porn
networks for you can work i  t simple
cases export york motto coffee dancer
flow to what ever rottersdorf is
happening waf matt machine learning
quick path magic ist partys dealing with
data interested transforming bring
far away dodge keeps you give you a
nice to have played class der der first
date set by a  transformers and
transformers a talking about face
for computer vision black image and
disappointing stuff you have a data
loader of a sampler new feature on
jupiter lepping
now returns so petritsch date of this
simple class ribbon interface on
different can have the corset of a counter
core and relax in  the data center
from this get one element of the game
set match loses dogs and cats days at
hear my name is not the vader project
are from the dogs kate sample train the
players said is still big lots download
it looks like an der data robotics inc
exempel folder which contains trade and
[music]
we have to have no one's for you have to
implement functions and  you just a few
days at sea dealing with open source of
files reading this is a very nice
abstraction 2016 wien
if that is now implemented by you get
alpin daisy a ghetto image and here
the label such a network image online
image and really have to implement
bridal dress  of the most functions data
safe mode combines functions exempel
you can get the catalyst of classics from the
seat took two the images and the
corresponding class lust am combine
drinks you don't have to bed and here's
looking at the images
ok
a scenario i have we  can get date of
computer vision violently into the craft on
site there are where kilo images that once yes
how many computer vision june arguments
der chalk bid for example with you want
to the top of your image but that's the
same to me here as duran group of
the stock a cross on don't wanna do
one transform montebourg transforms so
here is doing horizonte flip sometimes
you can nike implements transform
functions sergej rempel  interface and
easy to implement once clear
that one ends there so loud youtube
composite transforms so maybe you first
one flip one rotation or maybe what
they want sometimes it makes sense to
have the power to compose your image
argumentation pipeline one view think
of carols otto office  home and asian
both merial limited and weekend you
like it offers juris limited belongs as
it says according to epson server and you can just do
it but you can't we have the wiener
compost false richards and image spot
showed
josef random koller twitter widgets nice
so to speak  view cisco network general
this time later so ok and in the
development do as sir
related information here
because how journey into cancer and reload
as normal as should there is normal network
and expenditures standard value bets
formation and now you don't get much
anymore both  dancer okay the af view also
image and people at base would
you can use plugin tuifly crazy
transforms in cra  zy stuff image
documentarian rebic who disappoints as a tutorial
sonim and transformations in
the office protection kilo scm which
is extremely simple pence other
operations importer in stolp ilo sms
sms with faster remseck some people
complain about michael oslo a first
time fun that he exactly the internet  the
google just like the search for image
moment rule but the lord
maybe research gorbachev
strategies for how to do is mention
general richard state-of-the-art results
in band of kings of course the
implementation that means before the
google project management you can  use
that light radiation with her of course
waiting for him too much
okay for data one concept to g data to
get one day point of you want to get
lucky batch of data and purchasing cover
the data loader raciti jetset in can
return patches of fate multiprocessing
so  wittmeier roger wardin is michael
leighton now there is so basically what
i do you create a data loader  you pass
the day that you can find the chase and
you can say you want to date and does it
makes sense was at the fashion week
and numbers of workers are two for you
can get any trade office training data
loader of the cortex function and here's
something  here the execute
if you want to create the transformers
the data loader expectations and day the
set the return to trade may transforms
the transformers and transformers the
data loader networks and i get that
causes of cool images two of the people
should color and the size of two  three
four three for plasma the witches of the
screw my label switching spector
labels patches to know that we can get a
bunch of images the edge of images to
data loader transforms dorf but
sometimes you want to have more control
about how you get what you get  me you
want the dogs and cats on the same
relations ventoux dogs and cats in the
domain and ford edge gateway on the
sampler the sampler stacey kent
over team it is s  super simple
interfaces implemented and return
net index of what you on access in
your nwz
take that you have to return
christoph in the starting this last
yes we here is an example before the
sampler have to implement a ita function
and here waiting generate return is liker
per mutation of the seas none of the
testers and medion i have to implement a
function and you get the way beyond data
loader combining place may dugard
bachelors of data plus multiplexing of
sampler is like remote control about
that had problems implemented in the pretty much
like all  this classic
from the 11
the sampler of the 11 if he now
says something else you say it off like youtube
a school camp
the idea is simple
nor is the best practice for science
in transformers normal that at
yamaha small form compositing half just before
the industry satin production dancers
flow means collector of the colt end of low
transform medium from et do like crazy
transformations witcher because p  art of
computational graf if that were the
super nanny state that is maybe you're
motivation your okay training and
liable dogs and cats take that we
always have concerts as well as
dancing data safe des beer consumption so fans of
learning machine learning basically
hughes network systems network  is going
to paint net data said the new president
network and i have this place to work
for like class what's going on the
features in the news classified sr
düsseldorf
in the recording from the classic even
the duke of a slave who do you wanna
have to  train
which is just a few parameters are not
the material passe
metzger standard imports if thorsten
torch imports basically we're going to
use motogp coach as well as the finals
if paid content services data model
los optimizer training gut so
[music]
before a notebook with des  plans for
monday to review the hunter harrislee
difference from before malware detection data
said they don't really argue data
bei much fu  n to any flipping sami
allagui joan armatrading transform and
variations form because import dogs and
cats are used to be something for data
center
die nation data loader with get the
foundation date special force for
workers are we have our day dominik
benita model like nicolas minijob
together  in the newspaper to transform
and ken user pre trade network and
ipod offers a bunch of free trade
networks by aleksander
kwasniewski smiths net inception vistream gmbh place
solactive and tricks offer boss den us
manager for the new and travel network
weekend as if i were just printer  model
look
that is necessary network is that we
have the great eight or to handle the
motive one of the interesting bad is in
hesse so far test fully connected
ligna layer in the developer on input
features and pointed 1000
individual switch correspondent class
i have to do best of  the rest of the
trail of the model and set hewitt
relevant parameters supporter parameters
prompt quar  tett the means we were
calculated credit suisse -4 and update
open when he was there on chancellor in a gentleman
maybe wants herpers for example
the train the trainer burkhard is there
with otto premingers and model which do
have great keppel parameters have the
frozen switch das active  travel watch
institute for science and hear you sing
the parameter jan fries whatever works
the least nexans good at freezers fans
were star models a stranger countries
participated learning raid 1 or robert
mohr in the like progressive trade hat
you could have and learning rape
highland rape and very  end features was
really off ok we shot the model of a
parameter
but just replays last before the
connected longer economy love before
with lines 52 on im plaster and i'm going
to have to or puts out last year when
here
a man brings uwe koßel gender  check
inn en frozen never in new labor is
still out there at the ford escort model
displays in kitas creating motto be  cause
i'm going to create mode unfortunately is the
combine function image of the ex
activate tab you can do that with model
hairdressers places countries z a model in
los angeles in this case you smile
optimizer if here in the thread trainer
bin model parameters function and only
want  to optimize parameter switch and
trading bottom right on most
yes separated here this is morpho
baring at wrong people
lukas property talks model trade raining data
loader fans of the date of the model
told that allows you to back public
relations logistics diethard important
than ben  affleck here prima just for the
evaluation should now with the band
creates that is goods on the national
mall
that lasts until that is only a purely
electric car in the garage in
Großelfingen with the song money train
functions and you're strange that's it
with primates  new can do a bunch of
things from the asam libraries which would
help you to avoid the experience for
example which offers me  trics which is
great super value add in create super
at stricter
because every case models before here goes
ja los julia optimizer you can create
ist super white trainer was suitable model
the optimizer in the los value at risk
metrics that you want to calculate fcn
trainer
event  interests completed every country
bring so heftes comeback mechanism
mitchell from herten operations basically
missing you can't say that didn't write
and ride of function here
as a dancer bord
no
[music]
hello it would have logged your father always
that's us
[  Music]
and have watched the internet will das zur
tänzer bord it is on google with
visuals year training and competition
models and der iss an bord xvi
quad interface to take that allows you
to create something they say that scaler
training closer to watch your web tänzer
bordnetz  very easy to integrate via big
night
so here and doing that may model im
training always my trainer in mainz and
in becks relatively find out what ever  on the
internet in tomb raider in a then
news all the dancers flew goodness so often
times my training curves as
him a count isolation icon booklet
histogram great for the car neither at
pentax a person interfaces master
bender interface he
's such a battery he's facebook
so far pictures of  thought that you can
have my cell phone no rangers
interested gentlemen the users now on
the train to
mr hopp now from here to twitter and
on the internet lukas is there is a lot make
the new day network and stuff version of
just released and change is not dead  end
of low service is still very much a dancer
flossmann later but they really want
to focus and production of health
authority integrated coffee pot
repository facebook user coffee to go
into production service is in service
to keep low would be up to onyx
going to tweet too  export models in the
otto fleck with compiler if he
maybe look at the world ends
[applause]
herold net was k  urzen street
who thinks in your nwz
that was now then used car or
something for use high-level stp from the
dancefloor
i wanted to help and interviews mostly
a stefan at the back berlin the ewz
power products ebeam huge party in the
it is made for research and  aibling
but you can do you can use of tech blog
post its watchers in karachi
[music]
ab
die haben implementation of early
stopping by potash one a didn't
really can't remember 2.0 interface
hofmann botta of the early stopping the
very easy to  implement high level match
so almost of the course
[applause]